the question is what are typical
mistakes founders make in their first
meeting with you they should avoid
okay this is a great question what are
silly
stupid things that founders do
or you've seen that are just a mistake
when you're meeting with investors the
number one
is a lot of these founders are just they
really want to get the deal done
and they've they feel pressure to
basically
put their best foot forward and it's
pretty easy to stretch from exaggerating
to lying and when you're on the other
side of the table and you just
watch these folks all day long come to
the door
you get a really good pattern
recognition of when they're lying
and there's a lot of ways to trip
somebody up i'm constantly basically
trying to figure out
are they really a truthful person
because it's that's
one of the biggest things that is like a
red flag for me is
people that i can trust when times are
bad
and things are not working right to be
truthful and honest and open
and transparent about what's going on
because otherwise i just
it's really hard to work with people and
that's the biggest one and i see it over
and over again and it makes me sad
because it's
great entrepreneurs who i would love to
invest in but they're just liars and i'm
like i can't do this and
there's lying and then they're
stretching the truth there's
exaggerating
there's a whole spectrum here and i
think what's important
in what you're saying is as an investor
we know imposter syndrome we know that
you
don't think you're adequate we know that
you're concerned you only have three
paying customers
and one of them doesn't actually use the
product and the other one's your friend
from college
and you really at the end of the day
only have one paying customer
and we are okay with that because we've
invested in companies over and over
again
and watched this collection of ragtag
misfits and pirates create something of
massive value
from nothing we understand that so there
is no
actual need to exaggerate to us and
you're so correct because it always
comes out
i always find it out because i do math
in my head and i say how many customers
you have they say 100. i say
what does the product cost and they say
it costs 100 a month and i go 100 times
100 you get 10 000 in revenue a month
and they say i say okay you're doing 10
000 revenues no not exactly i'm saying
what are you doing revenue
yeah we're doing zero dollars and i'm
like you have no revenue you just said
you have a hundred customers like oh
that we plan on charging a hundred
those hundred people are in beta uh and
they're not paying and i'm like okay
great so you have users in an unpaid
trial
great if you had presented it as users
in an unpaid trial i'd be like oh that's
great
tell me about the top 10 how are they
using the product
whatever your attraction is however
modest it is it's something and it's
better than lying okay next question
and this is from the dude and when the
dude has a question it's going to be a
good one it's coming hot
what do you think about white labeling
tech to help build or finance your core
product
it's a great question coming in hot dude
what do you got zach
i always say that anything you can do to
get
to sort of like sarah table has a great
saying where she's like the red hot
center
of your business and whatever you can do
to make the other parts
easier and faster to get to that spot
the better and white labeling technology
whatever you have to do totally fine now
at the end of the day you still have to
basically be able to tell a compelling
story about how
how you really are a technology business
and how there is a moat
around your technology and how your
technology enables you
to grow really rapidly and it you won't
become commodified
so if you're using the same technology
that everybody else has access to
that's going to be challenging when it
comes time for competition to show up
and they're always going to show up and
if you don't have the ability to protect
yourself investors are going to look at
you very differently than if you've you
know built your own proprietary stuff
but getting to that sort of core proof
point to validate the idea
the business and the value that you
deliver to a customer
and then building out from there is
a great idea yeah and by the way sarah
taval general partner over at benchmark
was on
angel season 4 episode 4 back in
february great guest
she's pretty great i think it was one of
my final guests in the studio before
kovitz started wow that's crazy to think
about if you're
doing white labeling as well and you
mentioned here dude
the dude sorry i didn't mean to be a
casual there with you dude sorry
mr dude it's a great way for you to keep
the lights up and some people are very
precious
about oh just raise money and stay
focused but the truth is you may not be
able to clear market with investors you
may be an outsider or whatever
if you get three people to take a white
label version of your product
and you own all the code and they're
giving you 5 000 a month each or
15 000 a year each and that keeps the
lights on
great keep the lights on and then you
can launch the
web-based product that is not white
label for everybody else based on what
you learned on their nickel i'm not
precious about it
whatever it takes to get to product
market fit to get that
burning ember at the core of your
product not a problem now
if you do have a consumer-based product
and you're like should i have a white
label and a consumer those are two
businesses
yeah hard to run both in the same
company isn't it zach
absolutely i that's another to go back
to the first question we have like
what's a
you know red flag whenever you have two
different
things going on that have different
focuses and different
like areas of attention that are
required and you have to make different
decisions for those two things
it's a huge red flag for me because at
the end of the day when you actually
find product market fit
what happens is that the things that
used to be really hard
revenue customers traction actually
becomes really easy
because all these people see this value
and they just come running for what you
have
and you start growing really rapidly but
what happens is all the things that used
to be
easy managing your company scaling
keeping up with growth becomes really
hard because you're growing really
rapidly
and when that happens entrepreneurs need
to be
really focused on basically growth and
they need to go from basically
putting their energies against making
things work to putting their energy
towards
simplifying and making things simple so
that it can keep up with that growth
and what i find is that if you're
distracted doing multiple things
you get totally crushed during that
period and also it's a really good
indication that you actually haven't
found product market fit
because every entrepreneur i know who
once they find it they get that idea
really rapidly and they start discarding
everything that gets in their way of the
one thing that is 10x
that is growing like crazy yeah the most
famous example was
groupon and the founder had started
groupon
inside of another company that was doing
like petitions and
lobbying this petition website and then
people started using the petition
website to petition
to get two for one meals yeah yeah yeah
yeah he was like wait a second
there's a restaurant downstairs let's
see if we can petition them to do this
and i was like
okay it's a petition they were like you
know what who cares about this petition
to get
buffy the vampire slayer back on tv or
whatever or the stupid comedy central
thing back on
let's just focus on a lot creating
customers through deals and they created
an entire category
and as andrew the founder of uh a
groupon tomy
it wasn't even his choice the entire
company didn't want to work on what was
slow growth they all just moved to the
side of the ship where all the fish were
coming in and everybody just stuck their
fishing rods
and went to the other side of the ship
to go fishing on the other side
every startup needs to ensure they own
their intellectual property or ip for
short and
that starts with filing your trademark i
have
been filing trademarks for 30 years
and i know what i'm talking about it's
one of those things that people forget
to do
or they put at the bottom of their list
and i understand that it's a pain in the
neck
but it is not a pain in the neck anymore
if you don't know where to start
look no further than brain base file
it's a clean
simple and automated trademark filing
platform
that gives anybody the ability to
protect their best ideas
there is no need to spend thousands of
dollars on lawyers
to file your trademark for you no now
you can do everything yourself
in just a few easy steps brain base file
gives you
goods and services recommendations using
ai so you can avoid the back and forth
with the u.s patent and trademark office
uspto and you can eliminate human
error they also offer full transparency
into the uspto process with step-by-step
notifications
and real-time updates on your trademarks
approval this is a process folks
so save a ton of money just head to
brainbase.com
twist and enter the code twist at
checkout
to file your first trademark now for
just a hundred sixty nine dollars that's
a fifteen percent
discount that's right brainbase.com
twist and enter the code twist
at checkout to file your first trademark
now for just a hundred 169 dollars